So there were sadly suspicions that there
may have been police officers who either stood
aside or even helped the Trump rioters on
January 6th.
And sadly, it appears that this is true.
We've now learned that several members of
the United States Capitol Police have been
suspended, according to Acting Capitol Police
Chief Yogananda Pitmen.
Earlier yesterday, Congressman Tim Ryan, a
former guest on this program, said that two
officers had been suspended.
One officer took a selfie with one of the
violent insurrectionists.
Another gave them a tour of the Capitol building,
according to Congressman Ryan.
Tim Ryan also saying that there are 10 to
15 ongoing investigations into officer conduct
during the insurrection.
This was at a press conference given yesterday
by Tim Ryan.
Ryan also indicated that a third individual
has been arrested, but said it's not currently
clear if they're a member of the Capitol Police
or the National Guard.
And this is I mean, listen, there's a few
different things that have to be talked about
here, first of all.
We were cautious when the theories started
that this was a plot and that Capitol Police
in advance were planning to usher in protesters,
and I said as those theories started to be
presented, let's be careful about that, because
we don't have evidence of that yet.
When we saw, you know, a 15 second video of
police clearing some barricades and that was
pointed to as evidence of a conspiracy involving
the Capitol Police.
I said we have to be careful because anybody
who knows about crowd control knows that once
you know, you are overwhelmed and your physical
barriers will not hold, you do move the physical
barriers to avoid others and yourself getting
hurt and trampled by the barriers themselves.
And so I urged caution.
And indeed, what we know.
Listen, I think one of the important things
is if your view on police is radically different
today than it was around the George Floyd
protests, then you should question whether
your view is tuned to reality during the George
Floyd protests.
My view was that based on everything I knew,
most police officers are doing their jobs
to the best of their abilities.
And most police officers are becoming officers,
generally speaking, for the right reasons,
because they want to protect their communities,
do do do something that's good for their communities.
And there are a lot there are too many bad
actors that slip through the cracks due to
lack of systems that prevent them from doing
so.
And so when you're talking about an apparatus
as large as law enforcement, there's no doubt
that there will be horrible people in a group
and a bad apple can spoil the bunch.
So it's not a surprise that now we are starting
to see two, three people suspended, a dozen
under investigation.
I'm sure that there are more than two officers
involved last week and potentially even even
military folks as well.
The investigations are ongoing.
That behaved absolutely atrociously.
Eventually there should be firings and not
suspensions.
But I think it's also important that, you
know, when we jump into the conspiracy theories
or when we start making the claims that aren't
based, in fact, we become just as bad as them
and there's no reason to do it.
Eventually the truth is going to going to
come out.
The suspensions are happening.
The arrests of the rioters are happening,
and it's all happening.
And remember, there are also people in law
enforcement who acted heroically last week.
Eugene Goodman is a Capitol Police officer
who is rightly being hailed as a hero, who
realized what was going on, realized that
the armed that the violent insurrection, some
of whom we suspect were armed, were getting
into the direction of the Senate chamber in
which there were senators.
And Eugene Goodman lured these rioters in
the opposite direction.
Eugene Goodman made himself a decoy.
So let's take this a step at a time.
Yes.
Investigations.
Is anyone surprised that some when you look
at the percentage of of law enforcement that
voted Trump?
Of course, in that there are going to be some
people that are carried away by what they
love to see, there were people in law enforcement
who loved what happened last week.
Some even participated off duty.
So, of course, we're seeing this.
So the investigations must continue.
We need attention to be devoted to investigating
supervisors and leadership to figure out what
happened.
And that means both supervisors and leadership
who ignored the signs that were there that
this was likely or probable to happen.
And that needs to be investigated as well.
The difficult part is that for every two that
actually helped in a way that warrants a suspension
like the two that have been suspended so far,
there were a bunch that sort of were OK with
it and kind of look the other way.
And it wasn't criminally negligent, but it's
still very problematic and that is much more
difficult to weed out and to deal with.
But again, most of the people on duty were
just doing their jobs and they effectively
ended up abandoned by management and colleagues.
Anyone that watches the videos can tell that
a vast majority of the police on scene were
doing their jobs and they were putting themselves
in harm's way and very importantly.
Any officer that was involved in any way must
be fired, they must lose pension progress
that they've made and it must be taken extraordinarily
seriously, you're not going to change political
views by doing this.
I understand that if you're a trumpet's, then
you get fired because of your role in the
riots.
Trump is a police officer.
You don't all of a sudden become a progressive.
I understand that it would be naive to think
so.
But the point is, much like the point I made
about the need to find an arrest and charge
and throw the book at the rioters themselves,
which is that and we're going to talk momentarily
about the risk of more of these riots coming
up in the next week, eight days.
If the punishments aren't severe, they will
be encouraged to do it again.
And that's the biggest risk.
And it seems that it is sadly
going to happen.